let's jump into this first story and
just we're going to start off light you
know we're not going to
just ease our way in with jokes about
trump and speeches and stuff now we're
going to we're going to be very calm and
pentagon document warns the world is
moving closer to a nuclear war because
russia and china are developing new
nuclear missiles bombers and submarines
are you familiar with the uh the fourth
turning darren yes no i'm uh
good friends with steve a previous guest
and that's a yeah topic of his as well
um right so yes so there are fears that
the crisis scenario so if those aren't
familiar with the fourth turning there's
like four seasons
the one we're in now is supposed to be
the crisis and it may be a domestic
crescent maybe international but we've
got the pentagon a report coming out
right now saying the encrypt there's
increased potential for region for
increased potential for regional nuclear
conflict with the country's main enemies
russia china north korea and iran
there's another uh big story that broke
uh just in this past week that satellite
research shows china building 119
nuclear missile silos
now this could be a strategy for what
they call like a whack-a-mole strategy
where china the u.s did this in the 70s
they built a bunch of missile sites and
then crossed their fingers hoping that
russia would target the wrong ones that
may be what china's doing but we also
heard from china that china state media
said that if we want to investigate
kovid they want to just build more and
more nukes and shivers down our spines
so
i don't want to be overly pessimistic
but uh i don't know how you how do you
guys feel about building the potential
for something doesn't mean that you're
heading towards that thing so
i don't like the way they phrase the
title that we're headed towards i'm you
know
just sounds like you know arsenal
building yeah i mean it of course
there's there's certainly a threat there
but i interpret these sorts of things as
the pentagon basically asking for a
bigger budget
yeah and you know you have to interpret
in the context of all this weird ufo
stuff which i think also fits into that
category and basically
i think the pentagon and the broader
national security apparatus with the end
of the war on terror effectively with
the withdrawal from afghanistan they
need to rely on two major
griffs and one of those griffs i think
is a cold war 2.0 with china and this
fits into that category and the second
grift unfortunately is the domestic war
on us
yeah that's that's their next grip and
those are the two chief imprimaturs of
the national security apparatus right
now is this cold war 2.0 with china and
this domestic war on terror which if by
that effectively they mean the war on uh
70 plus million people who are trump
supporters or trump adjacent or just
generally uh fed up with our corrupt
dysfunctional and possibly illegitimate
ruling class that's a really good point
actually so if you think about what's
going on in
every every uh world of the culture war
or every faction
you've got
people who are on the right concerned
about china very much so and so of
course they ham it up like oh oh man a
war worse coming and i've talked about
it quite a bit right then what happens
is you'll end up with republicans being
like we need to make sure we have showed
up our defenses bigger budgets for the
war machine to defend us
does the left care about going to war
with china no no well
for the most part so what do they care
about
the white supremacist terror threat you
need to give us more money to increase
our we increase our budgets because of
these these evil trump groups here's my
favorite one is the hat trick the ufos
now what happens if they can't get the
culture war left or right the crackpots
are scared of aliens tell everybody the
aliens are out there give us more money
right no i mean that's absolutely true i
do think depends on what level of
um
uh how intricate we want to be i think
ultimately there is a connection between
the kind of
the quote-unquote woke ideology that
animates the domestic war on terror and
our broader geopolitical aims and
strategies i think there's actually um
an underlying congruence there that
really needs to be
um explored rather than just oh here's a
bunch of woke stuff or culture war stuff
that serves as a distraction or we just
kind of tack it on to everything else
there is an element to that but i think
what's lost in that discussion is um
really
the degree to which there is method to
the madness and that the woke ideology
itself is deeply integrated not only to
our power structure domestically but how
we project power and affect our
geopolitical aims overseas
how does that work well
the short version for that is uh so at
revolver.news uh my news site one of our
first really big stories was
um exploring this concept called the
color revolution and noting that
there was a color revolution basically
being affected domestically in the lead
up to the election
and this generated extreme controversy
and everyone was apoplectic i think part
of the reason for that is that there up
into that point there was all this talk
about this kind of vague
amorphous deep state
whereas the color revolution implicated
a very specific faction of the deep
state and that specificity i think
worried people
and just in a nutshell a color
revolution is basically you're not going
in like iraq sending troops you're not
blowing stuff up you're basically using
mobilized mobs that are mobilized by
uh non-governmental organizations that
you have in a target country and they're
ginned up by the media and various other
uh
organizations and they're mobilized on
the basis of social causes so in eastern
europe you see mobilization of women
students to like go in the street and
protest against whatever target
authoritarian you have and in other
places in china for instance you see the
kind of color revolution technique being
employed in terms of
um exacerbating or weaponizing existing
ethnic cleavages so you have uh a lot of
focus on on the uyghurs for instance um
in myanmar you have the focus on the
rohingyas and so forth and so this
use of ethnic cleavages and this
mobilized protest
force that you see domestically that's
very much a part of this color
revolution method of achieving our
geopolitical aims abroad and i think
generally it's become
a part of how the united states
exercises its power and overwhelmingly
its power is still its soft power
notwithstanding all his talks about
nukes and so forth so so you're saying
it's happening here in the u.s we've
definitely talked about that and we've
gone over a lot of the beats on like
what it is here in the us but if it is
happening here who's who's doing it
well i mean i don't think we can
attribute it to any one person i think
it's
it's an institutional phenomenon and it
exists across every single institution
in the united states and the latest um
really big story that i've tried to
cover at revolver.news is and it's
difficult for people on the right to
really grasp is that the national
security apparatus traditionally thought
of as okay here's the last bastion of
people who i think their political
psychology
um inclines them to want to venerate
just and well-functioning institutions
of authority wells whereas i think
people on the left like to critique
unjust institutions of authority so it's
very difficult to get people on the
right who want to venerate just
institutions of authority to say look
the entire national security apparatus
including the military itself at its
highest levels has become
corrupted and infected and really
weaponized against you
and that's very difficult it's a
difficult process psychologically for
people on the right to understand but
it's happened across the board
institutionally that's why i've been
saying abolish the police
i mean for a long time i was like this
is ridiculous you know these cops are
out here trying to stop these riots well
then the da's did nothing
let most of the rioters go we can
clearly see that even if the cop
themself you know in them are good
people
they're funneling
everyone into the same direction where
the da's then say far left go free far
left go freya conservative to prison
with you far left go free and so my view
now is
if you sit back while this machine is
working it's it's it's a the house
always wins if it's a 51
victory for the casino and a 49 chance
for you sure you might win once or twice
but if you play in the you play long
enough the house always wins if that
pressure is applied right now through
these progressive da's in these big
cities then over time
the the the ultra woke individuals the
rioters the auntie for the blm they're
going to keep getting released and keep
being emboldened and anybody who oppose
them is going to keep getting locked up
or charged like we're seeing with the
with january 6th no absolutely there's
definitely a lot of truth to that and
you know part of the reason for this is
that you know the left or whatever you
want to call it really the
the ruling class
um has has been far more effective in
uh leveraging the infrastructure of
power
up to the da's you know it's this was
something that george soros identified a
long time ago that we want to basically
buy up all the da's and he understood
the implications of that so really you
know there's a lot to unpack in there in
terms of just understanding the
infrastructure of power which i think is
a tremendous weak point on on the right
and you see that in the just profound
asymmetry of power where like every
single institution including the
military is basically controlled by
uh
controlled by the left or this new
version of the left that we've seen and
basically the right has
zero institutional power yeah yeah yeah
what do you do with an ultra woke
military they're they're
telling everybody to do these trainings
they're weeding out quote-unquote
extremism
we've talked to a lot of people on the
show who uh or i should say there are
many friends of the show not necessarily
on the show who've said they gave up
their careers in military once they saw
where things were going
right well it's a it's a real question
because you have
broad swaths of the country who are
inclined toward patriotism and defending
the country and the people are more most
patriotic patriotic toward this country
are the people most hated
by the dominant institutions of the
country so how long is that type of
dissonance sustainable i think it's a
lot more sustainable than we would think
just because people are good at deluding
themselves but it's it's not
ultimately sustainable thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you